Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I remember the Krill, which this is radiolab.
Today on this program we are calling it lost and found, right.
We have stories of getting lost and of course getting found now.
I think we're gonna, we're gonna make a little adjustment here. Recalculating.
Shift gears. Approaching emotional lift. Thank God.
I'll give it to me.
This next story is a very different kind of lost and found sort of a love story.
If you can tell us your name. Oh, here's the guy. My name is Alan London guard.
Do you want to say anything more than that? I don't know. Is this,
is this for like a credit intro?
Let people introduce themselves? Oh, I don't know. I don't have a title. Okay.
All right. So that sound the girl Emily,
we'll meet her a bit later for reasons that will become clear.
The story begins on a fall day in Brooklyn.
And so the day in question, um,
I guess was the morning of October 8th.
They're both living in this one room loft in Brooklyn.
And we woke up and you know, both 21 went about our daily routine.
And prepared to go. He was in art school.
She was taking some time off from art school to work for a local artist.
So she would take the bike and I would take the train. What was it morning like?
It was a beautiful day. It was, you know, sun was low in the skies there,
you know, long shadows. I strapped on her helmet and adjusted it,
took her bike out for her. We kissed each other goodbye and said,
I love you and I watched your ride down the street.
Mm.
It's early morning and then you know, on, I went down into the subway,
six hours later he's working in the studio doing some sculpture and he gets a
call from a cop and he just said, Emily, you,
she had an accident. She's at Bellevue. This is the address.
And I said, oh, I mean, do you have any more information?
He just told me that it was bad.
[inaudible]
I was like carrying a bunch of stuff and I just dropped everything and started
running
[inaudible]
now Alan and Emily had only been together nine months,
but when it started says Alan,
it was just so immediate. The night they got together,
they both just kind of knew.
It was sort of like a weird prophetic kind of thing where I think it was the
first day that the school has had a snow day. It was snowed out.
It was kind of like this past blizzard, you know,
sort of like the city shuts down, magical kind of thing.
He'd gone out with some friends just as the snow was coming down and we were
trapped at this party and that's where he bumped into Emily pint sized.
Cause he's big like you're destined eyes and very kind of,
I have trouble describing her voice. It's almost as if,
I know you guys are audio people, but it's like stereo. Almost.
Truth is they've known each other for a while,
but that night says Allen fireworks all of a sudden and it felt right.
So you had, you had a feeling this wasn't just a thing, this was a thing, right,
right. Or the thing, the thing, right. The thing that you think the sole thing.
Yeah. All right.
Well, Emily, uh, they've always been boys frowned to Emily. I mean,
Susan Garcia, Emily's mom, she says at first when Emily told her about Allen,
she thought, okay, so that's another boy. Right?
Emily seemed to have that effect on boys perhaps because she didn't really seem
to need them.
Here is someone who's been obsessed with art and it's given up every body in her
life for art. At the age of six,
she was creating her own comic books in junior high school.
She took drawing classes every night.
And then in high school she left us friends,
boyfriends to go to a high school of the arts in Florida.
No one stands in the way of her art. It's all she sees. It's all she focuses on.
But then she visited Emily in May,
a few months before the accident and she met Alan.
I met Alan and he was delightful. Um,
but there was a different look that I'd never seen in Emily's eyes before when
she looked at him and I didn't like it.
Tell us about the accident from your perspective. For My, for when I, yeah,
I was at work. I, you're in New Orleans mattering,
which is a suburb of New Orleans and I get a telephone call and I looked and I
saw it was Allen Allen has never called me before, answered the phone.
I said Hello Allen. And he said, ah, you have to come.
Emily was hit by a truck,
uh, 18 wheelers, semi truck.
And I took a breath and I said, Alan, is Emily dead?
And he said, no, but you need to get here as soon as possible. Six hours later,
her and her husband, Emily's dad, we're at Bellevue hospital here in Manhattan.
They brought us into the, her Roman surgical ICU.
We all went in, she was just lying in bed and they were tubes, tubes down,
her throat coming in and out and her face was so swollen.
Emily covered in blood wait at probably at the time of the accident,
about a hundred pounds and she then weighed 128 she had swollen 28 pounds.
She had multiple fractures in her leg and her pelvis and the left side of her
face
open her abdomen and they had taken her intestines out and put them on top of
her body so that she could breathe
and she was just lying completely still.
You know that first 48 hours, nothing moved.
Not Nothing. We took up shifts, you know,
her mother would be there in the day and her father in the evening and then I
would be there with her.
Her eyes weren't even flickering and as she sat there watching Emily not move,
she says, she kept thinking, why?
I've got these four kids and everything bad seems to happen to Emily starting at
six months. Wow. Ear Infections than sinus infections than asthma.
Then by kindergarten,
Emily was losing her hearing for reasons no one could quite figure out.
She had to get hearing aids on both sides, but somehow
her mom says, all this just made Emily more fierce.
If anyone can conquer this, it's Emily.
I think on the second day they started to take her off her medication,
expecting to see some sort of reaction from her and
nothing,
nothing.
There was a nurse and the nurse said that Emily was gone and asked me about
organ donations. And I said yes. And so,
um, I worked up enough courage to go into what they call the track room,
which is where the residents usually are.
And there was one woman residents sitting at a computer and I went and I said,
when are you going to let Emily go? And she,
so we will have a family meeting tomorrow morning and we'll talk then.
And so I said, okay. And I, I left and I went back and,
and I'm sitting with Emily side of her bed and I'm telling her,
Emily and I read the book, the bridge of San Louis,
right when she was a sophomore. And I remember the ending of the book.
There's a land of the living,
there's a land of death and the bridge is love and that love is the only thing
that survives and is kind of the weight goes.
And so I was sitting there with Emily and I was telling this to,
I was saying this and talking in her ear and saying this and talking to her and
telling her that I would love her eternally through all time.
That I love with never end. And Emily raised her left hand.
Did
I got it. I can wait. What was it was, it was chaos.
I was yelling for the nurse. I saw it. I saw her move.
That was really one of the really abrupt moment. Yeah.
Now they knew Emily was not dead. Emily was alive,
but how alive
over the next few days says Allen, she slowly started moving more,
not really in response to anything. She'd arrive in bed,
scratch her leg where there was a wound, we would hold her hand. Yeah,
and she'd slap, slap our hands away.
When they tell this to the doctors, the doctors would say,
that's not indicative of any kind of mental functioning. Could just be a reflex.
Really. So the medical team began trying to determine just how damaged was,
see the ophthalmologist teams were coming in and they were trying to get Emily's
eyes to eye pupils to respond and they weren't responsive.
And so I knew what that meant. What did that mean? Image? She could be blind.
So Emily couldn't see, couldn't hear because remember she wore hearing aids.
And why didn't you just put those in? We tried,
we tried many times to put it in, but she just wouldn't allow it.
But what you do exactly when you did it,
flail her head shake around kick and she would hit,
had a lot of bruises on my body where kicked me and pinched. So we, we stopped.
We every once in a while we would go back to it, but there was the question,
you know, um, maybe she couldn't hear anymore. So what do you,
what do you do to a WHO's key?
You don't know what's going on inside her and you can't get to her. Um,
you send it to a nursing home and you know,
that's where she would have remained. And after several weeks in the ICU,
Emily, she was stable and that meant they had to make a decision.
Once you become stable,
then you have to move off surgical ICU and out of the hospital to either a
rehabilitation or to a nursing home. So that became the new question.
Where would she go? Could she be repaired, so to speak?
In which case you'd go to Rehab or is it for her,
in which case she'd go to a nursing home.
Now making that call medically is um, sometimes tricky.
That's Dr McCalla Eisenberg.
She's a physician at NYU and it's her job to make that call.
And she says one of the key criteria for getting someone into rehab to do Rehab
on somebody, you need to have them reacting to you.
A person needs to be able to participate in a meaningful way for three hours of
therapy a day.
They have to be able to follow commands because that's how you rehabilitate
someone. If the person can't hear, if the person can't see,
then there's no way to communicate with her.
And so they made the assessment that she could not go to rehab and that Emily
should go to a nursing home.
Mm.
So is that my husband back to New Orleans to look for a nursing home?
Did they can bring her back too?
They just kept it all secret from me that they were going to take her away from
me. I mean, how do you
tell someone who loves your daughter that much? That we're taking her away.
But there was not just one life that we had in our hands. It was two lives.
We felt that that would be the best thing for him.
Um,
and Alan could hate us.
[inaudible]
maybe as a way for him to bridge and let go for that grief.
but then as the doctors are prepping Emily to move her to a nursing home,
they had to remove her tracheotomy, which was helping her breathe.
And she all of a sudden started talking. Really? She, she spoke? Yes.
What was she saying? She would curse. Don't touch me.
You blanked a blank. You know, she would say, stop.
This was in response to someone touching her, touching her.
And if she wasn't cursing, says Ellen,
she would call everybody Miss Dash would certain people that were touching her
where mustache would, oh,
that's from sense and sensibility quoting Jane Aust Yellow. Yeah.
We had watched the movie like a couple months previous to this,
so somehow she was locked in the movie and it was just the assumption of the
doctors that she was just sort of mentally damaged.
But if she's calling people Ms Dashwood, doesn't that at least mean something?
No, it wasn't enough to say that Emily could follow a command,
like set up, raise your right hand. So the plan was still the nursing home,
right? I mean though, every possibility had not been exhausted. I can see him,
he was sitting across the room and his jaws were just clenched.
It just was not going to give up. And he was saying,
you have to give her a chance. She, you have to give her the chance.
You have a plan. No, I had no plan whatsoever. No, that was lost.
This experience was just completely traumatic to me emotionally.
But at the same time, I was going to help her in whatever way I could. Uh,
the only trajectory I had was to help her. And One night,
just a few days before Emily was going to be discharged to a nursing home away
from him, I was there alone with her and his 3:00 AM or something,
and she was calm. Like she wasn't trying to fight me away or anything.
I had helped her fix a thing that was wrong with her, uh,
mouth wiring. It was like a wire that was poking her and I fixed it for it.
And he says at that moment something occurred to him. I really just was like,
in the recesses of my mind,
he thought of the story of Helen Keller and Annie Sullivan.
He'd read about it a few days earlier online and he thought, hmm,
what if I tried what Annie Sullivan did with Helen Keller on Emily?
I took her left hand with my left hand and I leaned over and using her wrist as
the baseline for the words in his finger is the pen I just wrote.
I waited a second. Oh, wait a second.
Oh, wait a second.
The he waited a second.
You then, according to Allen, she said to him, she said, Oh,
you love me. Thank you.
She literally replied immediately because she knew who, you know,
she has no idea who I am.
Uh,
now we had a way to get to her so he could figure out how much of her was
actually there and maybe even prove it to the doctors. You know,
I had to have something that was conclusive to present to them.
The following evening,
I took out my cell phone and it has a record function on it and I started
recording
question after question to determine her Tonya disability.
What is your name?
What? W? H. A. T.
[inaudible].
Yes, I am
[inaudible]
you finger spelled every letter? Yeah.
Hi.
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]. Hi it. Hey
[inaudible] she's writing her name on the poem of Mine and
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Alan called me four o'clock in the morning and said, you have to come now.
I have proof.
No, I'm going to ask her what year it is.
What? Hi,
I'm going to ride year.
[inaudible] question mark.
[inaudible] Emily. Very good. Very, very good.
Do you know where you a question mark?
Okay. Right now I'm going to ride hospital
that there are about four 45 in the morning.
Alan is over there by the bed continuing to finger spell and talk to her and
she, she calls him Allen.
She knows that this person who is finger spelling on her hand is named Allen,
but Alan can't get her to understand who he really is. That it's her ally.
I'm just going to write my name again. Alan.
She just couldn't make that mental jump to connect her past life with her
present.
Hello? [inaudible].
Are you a Jian? Am I Asian? Tell her no.
Next thing I hear her say is
pull me out of the wall. She kept saying, pull me out.
Please pull me out a few. It's dark in here. Pull me out.
Help me know you can do it. Pull me out of the wall. I kept saying I can't.
I would write on her hand. I can't. Allen starts to sob and I'm crying too.
What are you thinking at this point? Wasn't enough. That wasn't enough.
It wasn't enough and I said, Allen,
ask her about her hearing aids and so he finger spelled hearing aid aid and she
said, okay. He agreed with the hearing aid and for the first time,
so we put it in and switched it on. He said,
Emily, Emily, can you hear me? Me, Alan. And immediately
everything came back to me. I was [inaudible] everything.
The door opened and Emily stepped
out. She was back. Yeah.
It's just a hearing his voice and you always had an eye.
He's an anomalies day and I heard her say what?
I had been waiting for her to say all those weeks [inaudible] she said,
Mama, no, I couldn't leave her there the whole time.
We asked Emily before she came back, where was she?
I didn't know where I was.
If I could see at all and I knew that I was sleeping and I was always dreaming.
She says people would come to her in her dreams and say, don't touch that.
Stop scratching your wounds. Nine genes, they blend in with reality.
She says she knew somehow that there are people around her,
but she couldn't get to them and that she also knew she was in a dream.
Why am I still sleeping? But you couldn't somehow wake up from, I felt helpless.
I felt really helpless. Where you waiting for someone like that?
I mean where are you? Cause I was waiting for
some communication, you know,
[inaudible] and I was really [inaudible]
Alan [inaudible] call to me
[inaudible]
Emily's now at the Rusk Institute,
which is one of New York city's leading rehab centers.
And on the day we visited her, she just had a breakthrough.
Today is the first day [inaudible] stand on both legs and walk,
actually walk.
I walked a hundred sheets actually today after rehab she'll be moving into an
apartment in lower Manhattan with Allen.
She's blind and the chances of seeing again are slim.
But Allan plans to spend his time helping her cope and helping her find a new
way to make art. Really. Can you, can you introduce yourself?
Say My name is ally. Yeah, just with, just so we have it all on tape.
They asked me if I would have a title and I couldn't think of one,
but I thought of one title. Yeah. And I'll do mine.
My name is Ellen llangoed. I'm the boyfriend.
My name is La Cossio and the girlfriend,
you're the star of the show.
If you want to know more about Allen and Emily, go to our website,
radiolab.org I guess, uh, we should go. Yeah.
Thanks for listening. You have reached your destination. Oh,
and thanks to Karen Jacobson.